every 16 iq points a woman goes up from  a hundred she's 40 percent less likely  to get married and every 16 iq points a  man goes up from 100 he's 35 more likely  to get married i don't think it's  unreasonable to point out that pursuing  a career and a family is more difficult  for women than it is for men again i  think that's because of the differential  commitment during pregnancy and for the  first couple of years and so it might be  that more intelligent women have a  harder time because they're more  interested perhaps in a broad range of  interests and perhaps of abilities it's  less obvious to them how to reconcile  that with the more traditional maternal  role i think that was pretty on point i  remembered going to a class that you  taught where you mentioned